back now at 7 30 here on CBS mornings
and we are talking about two key midterm
races in the state of Arizona races that
are tightening dramatically as election
day draws near let's go to the numbers
according to a newly released CBS News
Battleground tracker it is an even split
in that state for the race for governor
49 each for Democrat Katie Hobbs and
Republican Kerry Lake Democrat Mark
Kelly has a slight Edge over Republican
Blake Masters on the Senate side now
Lake and Masters have both spread lies
about the last election that'll keep us
in Tempe Arizona for us this morning Ed
good morning Dare I ask how are those
lies resonating with voters
well Tony good morning good to see you
as you mentioned uh those Republican
candidates others on the ballot also
pushing those lies about the 2020
election and it's one of the reasons why
we track things here in Arizona so
closely and yet according to our new
Battleground tracker most voters here
say they don't want that to be the main
focus of the campaign
[Music]
Carrie Lake won the Republican primary
for Arizona governor by fully embracing
the lie that the 2020 election was
stolen they certified a corrupt election
and that's the problem you would not
have certified our election no I would
not have but now she's locked in a close
general election and not emphasizing
that issue as much we're gonna have to
do what we did in the primer we just go
out and vote and take our friends and
get out there and vote like our life
depends her Democratic opponent Katie
Hobbs warns lake is too dangerous for
Arizona all of these people that Trump
has given his full endorsement to
because they support his big lie they
could change the rules and they could
overturn the will of the voters in
future elections but denying the results
of the 2020 election isn't a top concern
for voters in Arizona according to the
new CBS News Battleground tracker poll
more than half of even Republicans say
it doesn't matter we have so many votes
outside of the law but it's the main
focus for Republican Mark fincham he was
in Washington seen here in the crowd on
January 6 2021 and now he's running to
be Arizona's Secretary of State it's a
job that would put him in charge of
Elections ahead of the 2024 presidential
campaign that's why dear I'm a threat to
the left and they know they've got
somebody who is not going to let go of
this Democratic candidate Adrian Fontes
is especially concerned about what could
happen if fincham wins and Donald Trump
runs again for president he may not
certify an election that Donald Trump
doesn't win in 2024 as well this isn't
the most important election in our
lifetimes it could be the last free
election that we have in our lifetimes
our Battleground tracker also finds
modes to think abortion should be legal
and that comes as a judge has reinstated
a law dating back to 1864 that ends
abortion access in Arizona and with jail
doctors performing them that decision
upset longtime Republican Heather Carter
so much that she's now leaving the GOP
when you talk to women in Arizona and
they share their personal stories
one-on-one many of them are using this
issue as the deciding factor in the 2022
election and in the land of canyons
cacti and the Cardinals just like
everywhere else the economy and
inflation are the top concerns I see it
as a businessman that we're going to
hurt for the next 10 years this giant
wave that we're on is going to affect us
immigration is also a big issue of
concern here in Arizona perhaps no
surprise given that border towns
continue to see a surge in migrants and
on the issue of the 2020 elections
there's this from the poll a majority of
Voters say the vast majority in fact say
they want the next Governor whoever she
is to accept the results of future
elections no matter which party wins
Nate
Ed I used to live in Arizona it's
divided views around the country just
like it is in AZ we appreciate you